what's going on people today i have some
exciting news about the release date for
mikey academia season six which is being
reported by several reliable sources
according to multiple reports season six
is set to be released in fall of 2022
and to be more specific this likely
means october of 2022 as i'm sure many
of you remember the last season to be
released around that time of year was
season four which began streaming on
crunchyroll on the second week of
october and it seems like season six
will follow a similar trend
those of you who saw my video predicting
things about the upcoming season will
know that i thought it might be starting
in april but if they're taking more time
to give it the attention it desperately
deserves then that can only be a good
thing as i've always said the war arc is
my favorite storyline in my hero
academia so hopefully it coming out
later in the year means that they have
time to avoid the mistakes of season 5
which i think we can all agree it was
like the least hyped season in recent
memory
in terms of when we can expect a short
teaser trailer it's possible that one
will be coming out at jump festa this
weekend and i say that because as long
as i've been a fan of this series a
preview for the new season has always
come out at this event on the off chance
we don't get one i will keep you guys
updated on when the new trailer does
eventually release and i'll probably do
a breakdown as well so make sure you hit
that sub button with notifications on so
you don't miss that when it comes out as
always thank you guys for watching and
don't forget to check out my other video
where i explain what was wrong with
season five and how they can improve on
it in season six until the next one
peace out